it was argued that information in this
article about his mother visiting him at
school on his birthday was announced by
the palace the day before that this one
about his broken thumb like many others
merely copied information from other
newspapers and broadcasters Prince Harry
was asked whose phone he thought had
been hacked for the information the
doctors I'm not sure I can't be sure Mr
Green are we not in the Realms of
speculation asked the mirror's lawyer no
I don't believe so again I'm not the one
who wrote the article you'd have to ask
the one who wrote the article Harry
seems to be keeping his cool he's not
rising to
enter that's to his credit I think so
far we've had a lack of detail from him
as to precisely how he says the unlawful
information gathering has taken place
Prince Harry often referred to invoices
and payments to private investigators in
his statement saying there were eight in
relation to his mother it was suggested
in court that Princess Diana's phone was
hacked when the Daily Mirror was edited
by Piers Morgan who in recent years has
been a vocal critic of Harry and Megan
reference to this was also in Prince
Harry's statement the thought of Piers
Morgan and his band of journalists
earwigging into my mother's private and
sensitive messages in the same way as
they have me
and then having given her a nightmare
time three months prior to her death in
Paris
it makes me feel physically sick
hello
motivations this was Piers Morgan's
reaction uh he said your behavior was
vile and unjustified what do you think I
didn't see it
but I wish him luck with his privacy
campaign look forward to reading in his
next book
Harry also claimed private investigators
were paid for information that led to
these articles about his relationship
with Chelsea Davey and the intrusion
ultimately caused them to break up
specifically asked what information was
obtained from hacking for this report
about a trip to Mozambique Harry said
this uh the paragraph that says
Harry will fly back to Britain on
December 19th that not only is that a
security issue I can't begin to imagine
how they would find that information out
without blagging and flight blogging
could have been done through phone
hacking either way I'm not entirely sure
how these journalists one of those being
Jane Kerr how they would ever know what
date I'm flying and having the
confidence to put that in a national
newspapers
advertising my travel plans
his best moment the paper's lawyer tried
to counter that while articles were
sometimes intrusive and embarrassing the
prince lacked evidence they were
obtained illegally Harry often made the
point that the journalists who wrote the
articles should be quizzed about their
methods many are not coming forward to
give evidence for a man probably more
comfortable on a battlefield than in a
witness box making the point that he's
had the guts to be cross-examined Jason
Farrell Sky News